hi there everyone and welcome back to
the channel today's video is a super
special video because we are kicking off
a whole new video series looking at
optimizing the snot out of one of these
little guys this is a tiny whoop and in
this video series we are going to be
looking at every part of the drivetrain
of this little guy we're going to be
testing props Motors and esc's to get
the maximum possible performance whether
you're looking to fly for the longest
time or just just go as fast as possible
and beat everyone else around the track
in the next video I'm going to be
testing just a few tiny whoop Motors so
make sure you like And subscribe to the
channel so you don't miss that video
when it comes out but today we are going
to be starting with the easiest thing
that you can do to get way more
performance out of your tiny whoop you
don't have to change any parts don't
have to change Motors don't have to
change props all you have to do is
optimize your ESC settings you can do
this today you can do this right now and
you're going to get a whole heap more
performance for almost no effort so
let's not waste any more time let's dive
right into it and get those ESC settings
perfectly dialed in if you've been
following the channel recently you might
have seen that I'm wearing some awesome
new drone themed t-shirts I've been
working with an amazing designer to
create some bold bright Graphics
capturing my favorite moments in fpv
right now we're launching four designs
the drift Chase midair Motocross one
pack Bando rip and the mountain dive you
can get these Graphics as a high quality
print on a t-shirt or jumper like I'm
wearing or you can get them as a tote
bag notebook sticker or a face mask
check out the links down in the video
description before we dive into the test
results let me take you through the test
setup which is slightly different from
that that I've used for larger Motors
and props here we have the tiny little
0802 motor and prop connected to the
test stand obviously the motor is far
too small to mount directly so I've 3D
printed this adapter which stands the
motor off a bit and gives the prop clean
air to work with the motor is connected
to this piece of race wire and all the
motors have the same length wires for
this uh section here and that's
important because these wires are very
thin the race wire is for a 5-in drone
so it's got massive current carrying
capability and I've connected to it with
these thick 20 AWG motor wires and
that's running back to the ESC the ESC
is a BL heli s ESC with a 7 amp rating
and it's flashed to the blue J firmware
so that we have all the data from
bidirectional dshot that we need to
record the performance of the motor the
ESC is connected to another piece of
race wire which adapts it to these thick
wires which go to the test stand and
that's so that we can measure the
voltage and the current that we're
supplying to the ESC during the test the
test stand has this massive 50vt 10,000
microfarad capacitor and there's another
smaller capacitor on the ESC but in
parallel with all of that I've also
connected this newb drone nitron NR gold
battery to help keep the supply voltage
to the ESC very constant at 4 volts all
of this setup is kept topped up to 4
volts by a power supply with a 5 amp
rating which is plenty to hold
everything constant during the test the
ESC is connected to this flight
controller and that flight controller is
going to log all of the data over
bidirectional dshot from the ESC so that
we can measure the responsiveness of the
motor and the RPM that the motor
achieves under all of the different test
conditions now that we've looked at the
test equipment I want to run you quickly
through the methodology starting with
the KV test here we ramp the motor from
0 to 100% throttle at 3 volts with no
prop and we measure the Full Throttle
RPM of the motor at 3 volts dividing
that by three gives us a measure of the
motor KV and this might be slightly
different to the manufacturer's KV but
it is still comparable between different
tests the second test is a throttle ramp
here we put a prop on the motor and ramp
the motor to Full Throttle over 5
seconds and then back down again here we
can see the shape of the thrust curve
and we can also see the Full Throttle
RPM which is a measure of the Full
Throttle thrust that the motor is able
to achieve the next test is a response
test here we're stepping the motor from
10 to 50% throttle and Back Again
multiple times and we're measuring how
fast the motor is able to accelerate and
decelerate the prop the final test is an
efficiency test here we drive the motor
at 1 amp of current giving it exactly 4
wats and we measure the RPM that the
motor is able to achieve a higher RPM
means more thrust for the same power and
that means better efficiency all right
then let's dive into some data and we're
going to start by talking about motor
timing motor timing is how the ESC
controls when it drives a coil relative
to the position of the magnet in the
rotor if you've got a coil here and a
magnet in the rotor that is spinning and
passing by the coil motor timing
controls when the ESC will turn on this
coil to push the magnet round if you
have a timing of 0° the ESC will drive
the coil when the magnet is directly
opposite the end of the coil if you have
positive timing let's say 15° that means
that the ESC will drive the coil
slightly before the magnet arrives
directly opposite it and that gives time
for current and therefore magnetic field
to build up in the in the windings in
the coil and that allows the coil to
push the magnet past if you have too
little time timing you run the risk of
desyncs and too much timing you actually
have the coil pushing back against the
magnet trying to stop the motor spinning
before um the magnet passes the end of
the coil and pushes on so too much or
too little timing can be a problem let's
start by looking at timing versus motor
KV and motor KV is incredibly important
for tiny booop Motors the higher the
motor KV the more topend power you're
going to have and the effective motor KV
is affected by the ESC timing setting
what we can see is that increasing the
motor timing gives an improvement in
terms of KV it raises the KV that's
going to give you more top end power but
we don't see any Improvement Beyond 15°
of timing so going to 22 A2 or even 30°
doesn't give you any benefit over 15 but
you do see a big loss a big deficit in
lower timings 7 and a half and 0 degrees
giving you significantly less top end
power if we look at a 10-second ramp
from zero to Full Throttle and back
again we can see that the low timings
really have significant reduction in the
top end motor RPM and therefore the top
end thrust that you're getting from the
motor but 15 22 and A2 and 30° of timing
all give you the same maximum rpm and
therefore the same maximum thrust and
there's no benefit to increasing timing
Beyond 15° looking at efficiency now we
can measure efficiency by driving the
motor at 1 amp of current and 4 volts so
we're giving the motor exactly 4 w
and then we can look at the RPM that
it's able to achieve if the motor is
achieving a higher RPM and therefore
delivering more thrust at the same power
level we know that it's being more
efficient again we see a benefit of
increasing timing up to 15° increasing
the timing is increasing the motor RPM
that's able to be achieved at that 1 amp
of current that 4 watts of power and so
you're getting more thrust for the same
power and the motor is being more
efficient however once you get Beyond
15° the um the Improvement starts to go
back the other way we see there's
actually less efficiency at 22 and a
half and 30° of timing compared to what
we get at 15° so the efficiency is
reducing and we're not getting any more
topend power so there's no benefit to
going Beyond 15° and there is a clear
peak in efficiency at 15° of timing
looking at ESC timing versus
responsiveness we can see clearly that
there's no effect here the motor
accelerates and decelerates just as fast
regardless of the ESC timing setting
this data gives us a clear
recommendation on motor timing 15° of
timing is ideal for blue J esc's running
these very small motors a timing setting
lower or higher than 15° reduces both
the performance of the motor and its
efficiency now let's move on and look at
ramp up power I tested a whole range of
different ramp up powers and overall I
saw very little effect from this setting
there was no difference in motor
deceleration for any of the ramp up
power settings that I tried whether it
was one times all the way up to 13 times
or even turning ramp up power off
completely when we look at motor
acceleration there was a small effect if
I set ramp up power all the way down at
one times then that did slow the
acceleration of the motor but all of the
other settings the motor achieved its
maximum acceleration so in general
provided that you aren't setting ramp up
power at one times um you can pretty
much just leave this setting alone and
the default is probably absolutely fine
for these tiny Motors if you're looking
to make the most of your tiny whoop you
won't want to miss out on my PDF tuning
guides for betaflight 4.5 and blue J
esc's that are now available on my
patreon these guides will take you step
by step through everything you need to
know to get your tiny whoop tuned to
Perfection and flying better than it
ever has before you can't get these
resources anywhere else and not only
that you'll be supporting me to make
more videos like this for everyone in
the fpv community I'd really appreciate
it if you check out those links down in
the video description now let's talk
about pwm frequency because this has a
huge effect on the tiny Motors we use on
our whoops pwm frequency controls how
fast the ESC switches power on and off
to the coil whenever you're at less than
Full Throttle so if you're at 50%
throttle the ESC is very quickly
switching the coil on and off and it's
spending half the time on and half the
time off to give you 50% throttle PDM
frequency contr controls how fast that
switching occurs and there are three
settings 24 khz so 24,000 times a second
48k and 96 khz let's start by looking at
the effect on motor KV and pwm frequency
doesn't have any effect on motor KV
because motor KV is measured at Full
Throttle which means that the ESC isn't
switching when you have U the motor at
Full Throttle each coil is just driven
100% of the time and so the ESC never
switches and as we would would expect
that means that we get exactly the same
motor KV within the margin of error
regardless of the pwm frequency setting
the moment you start to look at less
than Full Throttle Everything Changes
because now we are switching power to
the coil and so the pwm frequency
setting is in effect and increasing the
pwm frequency actually decreases the
thrust at low and mid throttle but once
you get up to Full Throttle obviously
that thrust is the same across all the
pwm frequency settings because we're no
longer switching this giv a different
shape to the throttle curve for the
higher pwm frequencies with a sort of a
lower throttle curve initially that then
ramps up more quickly as you get closer
to Full Throttle now this shape of the
throttle curve could be a little bit
different to what you're used to but
don't worry because we can compensate
for it using throttle Expo I've crunched
the numbers on this and I found that if
you're moving from 24 or 48k pwm up to
96k pwm and you want to have the same
shape of the throttle curve so you want
to best match a linear throttle curve at
24 or 48 kpwm if you set throttle mid to
1.0 and throttle Expo to
0.25 that will effectively correct the
shape of the throttle curve for you and
match what you had before when you were
at 24 or 48 kpwm and this might be
really useful because I think you're
going to want to consider changing to
96k pwm it turns out that pwm frequency
has a huge effect on the efficiency of
these tiny Motors that we use on our
whoops if you move from 24K pwm up to
48k pwm then you can get an increase of
nearly
25% in terms of RPM at the prop when
you're driving the motor at a constant
current of 1 amp and a voltage of 4
volts that increase of 25% RPM is more
like 55% increase in thrust because
thrust is proportional to the square of
motor RPM moving from 48k to 96 K the
difference is a bit smaller we get an
increase of about 8% in terms of RPM and
that's maybe 177% increase in terms of
thrust but that is still very very much
worth having it's it's going to allow
you to fly for longer and if you're a
racer it's going to allow you to be at
higher throttle for more of the time and
that's going to allow you to race faster
to fly faster for longer I should be
clear though that this efficiency
Improvement is only seen at partial
throttle if you are always close to or
at Full Throttle you won't see any
efficiency difference between the
different pwm settings but if you're
cruising around with an average of 30 to
50% throttle you are going to see a huge
improvement from these higher pwm
frequencies unfortunately it's not all
good news with higher pwm frequencies
higher pwm doesn't really have an effect
on motor acceleration once you take into
account the fact that obviously you're
accelerating to a slightly different RPM
at higher pwm frequencies the the actual
acceleration rate of the motor is pretty
similar whether you're running at 24K or
96k pwm but when we're looking at motor
deceleration that higher pwm frequency
does significantly slow how fast the
motor is able to be decelerated by the
ESC so motor braking is less effective
at that higher pwm frequency but you
know we're only talking about maybe 10
20 milliseconds from a 50% to 10%
throttle deceleration and overall I
think the massive gains in efficiency
that you get from those higher pwm
frequencies are probably worthwhile even
if you do lose a lid of a little bit of
motor braking performance all right so
now that we've found the best settings
I'm going to take you step by step
through applying these to your ESC so
I've got my tiny whoop here and I'm
going to plug it into my computer over
USB and I'm also going to plug in a
battery to power up the ESC as well
there we go we powered up once I've done
that I'm going to go to ESC configurator
open the port selection select the
betaflight stm32 comport hit connect and
then hit the Big Green connect button
that will connect to the flight
controller and if we hit read settings
we can get all the settings for the
esc's on our tiny so we can see that
we've got the settings coming up here
the first thing we're going to want to
do is we're going to want to flash all
the esc's with the latest version of
bluej and select the 96 khz pwm option
so jump into flash all esc's then we've
got the firmware is going to be blue J
we're going to leave the ESC selection
as it is because that's going to autop
populate we don't want to change it and
we're going to select the latest version
version 21 and 96 kpwm once we've done
all that just hit Flash and then over a
few seconds all of the esc's on your
tiny whoop are going to be flashed to
the latest version of Blue J with 96 khz
pwm once all of the esc's have flashed
we can apply the recommended settings so
first off we are going to be turning up
this minimum startup power that needs to
be set to the maximum value for these
tiny little Motors to make sure they
start reliably similarly the maximum
startup power we can increase that up to
the maximum value as well that's going
to be absolutely fine for motor timing
we found that 15° was the optimum so
we're going to set that and leave dmag
compensation at low for RPM Power
Protection I mean you can leave this at
default but I always like to have it at
the lowest value where it doesn't limit
motor acceleration to minimize the
chance of power spikes so for me I'm
going to set that down to three times
and that should give me a fast ramp up
so fast acceleration of the motor but
avoid large power large power spikes
which might reduce my efficiency
everything else can pretty much be left
exactly as it's set the only difference
being uh the ESC power rating if you
have a board that's only for 1s then you
can set this to 1s if you have a board
board that's for 1 to 2s then you're
going to set this to 2s plus the board I
have is a 1 to 2s board so I'm just
going to leave it at that once you've
done all of those changes just hit right
settings and that is going to overwrite
all the settings on your ESC and now
you're good to go just changing those
few ESC settings is going to greatly
improve the flight performance of your
tiny whoop but it's not the only thing
we need to adjust we also need to look
at the motors and props that are
available for these tiny drones in order
to get the ultimate setup for the best
possible flight performance and that's
what we're going to be doing in future
videos so make sure you like this video
subscribe to the channel and hit that
notification Bell so you see my motor
testing and prop testing videos for tiny
whoops as soon as they come out and
follow along with me as we find the
ultimate combination of components for
your next tiny build I really hope
you enjoyed this video thanks for taking
the time to watch it and I'll see you in
the next one happy flying
[Music]